let's all pay our condolences to cats as
it fades away to the Heaviside lair the
film adaptation of the famous Andrew
Lloyd Webber stage musical finally hit
theaters on December 20th 2019 and
audiences have been passionately
avoiding the film ever since here's what
went wrong with cats well the box office
numbers have rolled in for director Tom
Hooper's misguided movie musical and let
it suffice to say they aren't exactly
the cat's meow in fact they're
absolutely abysmal initial Box Office
estimates predicted that cats would earn
about 15 million on its opening weekend
but when the film opened against Star
Wars the rise of Skywalker no less it
pulled in a dismal 6.5 million
domestically that is to say the box
office returns were effectively in the
litter box
cats barely scratching by the
star-studded film managed to 6.5 million
dollars well such numbers would be
acceptable for say a limited release art
film but it's completely unacceptable
for a tentpole Christmas release packed
with triple-a Talent particularly since
the film cost approximately 100 million
to make a poor outcome for cats was
rather expected but the severity of its
opening weekend failure is still rather
surprising not to put too fine a point
on it but this is a serious box-office
bomb we're talking about here
a major cinematic catastrophe 2.2
million dollars on a wide release
opening day means that basically no one
saw this movie meanwhile pretty much
everyone on the planet knew the film was
happening seems like more of a curiosity
just wasn't enough to get people into
those seats that lack of curiosity
killed cats we can't talk about cats
without talking about that soul bending
teaser trailer which was released back
in july 2019 what a day that was for
social media they say that all press is
good press but they clearly hadn't seen
the cat's teaser trailer before making
that statement many people reacted with
abject horror when they got their first
look at the sprightly CGI cats recoiling
in horror at all the chirpy celebrity
faces grafted onto furry bodies some
folks hoped against hope
the film was still very much a work in
progress I'm not sure are they're not
done like some of the shots like the one
shot of Jennifer Hudson right at the
ending it looks really bad
so wondering why they're not done though
a film is basically doomed if the
trailer becomes a meme based on how
dreadful it is especially if that
trailer is released less than six months
before the movie comes out and people
weren't exactly won over when the second
full cats trailer was released in
November 2019 we imagine they were still
trying to process what they'd witnessed
over the summer when a film relies
heavily on post-production VFX it takes
a lot of time to get just right rushing
the process is a really bad idea
particularly when filmmakers are busy
hailing the special effects as
game-changing and groundbreaking well it
sounds like a very special kind of
technology was used for this film
previews digital third technology to
create the most perfect covering of fur
these are people but they're cats and
this is kind of blowing my mind
Pixar movies have an average development
cycle of four to seven years from
concept design to finished animation on
the other hand cats only had seven
months of post-production to render
everything principal photography began
back in December 2018 and wrapped in
April 2019 Universal Pictures released
the teaser trailer a mere three months
after that and Katz was released to
theaters in December 2019 just a little
over a year after principal photography
commenced that's an absolutely insane
schedule particularly for a film that
requires so much post-production work
reviews for cats aren't just disparaging
they're devastating upon its release
critics pounced upon the film with sheer
sadistic glee and you can't really blame
them as of the making of this video
cats Rotten Tomatoes score stands at a
resolutely sad making 18 percent and the
selected pull quotes are essentially an
all-you-can-eat buffet
of brutality even Rolling Stones overly
precious reviewer Peter Travers had his
claws out writing this all-star all
awful screen take on the smash Broadway
musical easily scores as the worst movie
of the year
and arguably the decade cats shouldn't
happen to a dog and varieties chief film
critic Peter debruge certainly wasn't
any kinder it is ugly it is badly
directed it is an eyesore and these cats
look terrible
shortly after cats was released the
absolutely unthinkable happened
as Gizmodo put it in an unprecedented
move Universal is sending theaters of
hatched version of cats you heard that
correctly on the same day the film hit
theaters Universal emailed thousands of
theaters and let them know that a rush
package containing an updated version of
the film would be arriving sometime in
the next couple of days seems like they
scrambled and they rushed to re-edit the
film in fact as of the making of this
video there's even a viral tweet that
shows viewers how to know whether
they're watching cats 1.0 or what will
go ahead and call cats 1.01 the tweet
reads how do you know if you have the
old version look for Judi Dench's human
hand wedding ring and all what a time to
be alive check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bells so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]